Sometimes I think of it as a very pedestrian element.
It's something that doesn't have very many applications,
so it's quite easy to overlook, but at the same time,
some of those applications are actually really important.
So you have to remember that like a lot of elements in the periodic table,
it can be very easily overlooked,
but actually it's got some really fantastic uses.
When I think of the element home.
Ma'am I think of the English word huddle, which may sound a bit funny,
but it's because there's a simple way of remembering the names of all
the lanthanide rare-earth elements. Let me show you,
it begins with lanthanum and NGOs language
centers,
praise Ned's promise of you
put that in small European garden tubs,
dinosaurs, horrible erratically. Thrumming yeah.
Lou Lou. So there it is.
Number 67 holmium which you remember through the word hobble,
which begins with the same letters. H Oh, I learned this.
I think when I was at school, it's really great.
I can write the whole row of length night elements on the Blackboard or
whiteboard nowadays. And the students say, wow, I'm thinking I'm a genius.
M was first observed, not sort of isolated,
but observed spectroscopically by two chemists in
1878, one of them was called Mark Del Fontane.
And the other was called Jack was Louis SOA.
They saw this wonderful spectrum. Then they thought of that.
This must be something new and different.
They obviously great PR guys because they call the element act.
I don't know much about holmium except that it's named after Stockholm or the
Latin name for Stockholm.
I knew also that there was a lot of arguments when the element was first
discovered, who discovered it had, they discovered it had they not.
They had actually seen it and it's, it's a clean isolated state,
but it wasn't until a year later that it was actually isolated properly for the
first time. And of course,
one of the issues like with many of the lanthanides is actually isolating
holmium on its own because many of the lanthanides have a very similar size.
So you dig them out of the ground and minerals all jumbled up together and you
have to separate them out.
So you can put all the psyllium in one pile over there and all the holmium in
one pile over there. This is quite difficult to do,
but eventually people have figured out how to do it.
The other thing I know about holmium is the low temperature.
It exhibits very strong magnetism.
It's not much use at room temperature,
but because of the number of electrons,
unpaired electrons at low temperature,
you can get really strong magnetic effects. So a year later,
1879.
A guy called Pierre Trudeau,
Cleve manages to separate holmium on its own for the first
time.
And he decided to call it after the Latin for homier,
which is actually Stockholm, which is his native.
The T the electrons have a whole series of different energy levels,
depending whether they're paired or unpaired.
And the energy separation between these levels is not
very great. So as you warm it up,
the electrons have more energies. So some of them go into a higher state,
if you could live right down, they all go into the lowest state,
which in this case happens to be the really magnetic one.
So holmium has some very interesting fluorescence phenomena. Um,
so you might be able to find some kind of application where you need something
that for the rest is with a particular type of color.
One sort of spinoff from that is that it,
and we're back to this, uh,
nature of the absorption spectrum that our two folk found many,
many years ago,
that spectrum is very distinct and it almost never
changes.
The.
Strange arrangement of electrons means that if you put some in
glass, you can get quite an elaborate spectrum.
And we used to use [inaudible] filters to calibrate our
spectrometers.
Basically you would do a run with the holmium sample and check that the
spectrometry is calibrated properly so that when you record a real spectrum,
you know, that the peaks are actually in the right.
Place. We've searched everywhere in the lab,
but we don't calibrate spectrometers anymore. So we can't find the filter.
Well, I thought all elements had a really distinctive spectrum.
Are you saying the elements spectrums or not really? Yeah.
They can do. I mean,
the first thing is it depends what type of spectroscopy you're actually running.
Cause there are many, many different types. Then the second part is,
um, an element on its own. We'll have a very distinctive spectrum,
but also most elements don't turn up in the world or not found in the
world just as the element on their own. I mean,
obviously gold often is which is why it's used often in jewelry,
but most metals in the periodic table are dug out of the ground in the form of
oxide.
So you want to turn them into an interesting molecule to do something with them.
And usually when you're changing that environment around the metal,
you're changing its core electronic structure,
which that means that spectroscopy will be different.
But the lanthanides generally, although there are exceptions to the rule,
they're not really interested in what's going on around them. And in fact,
one thing I often teach our undergraduates is that whilst transition battles
change a lot,
depending on what's immediately bonded to the metal lanthanides by and large
are sort of screamed away from what's going on around them.
And so you can make a really impressive,
fancy molecule with holmium in the middle of it.
And you could record it's, uh, ultraviolet, visible electronic spectrum,
and it will look barely any different to the free iron in the gas phase.
Because as far as it's concerned, it's no different.
It's almost like the lanthanides are really antisocial and they don't want to
talk to molecules that bond to them. And the way the transition metals.
It is used in surgical lasers,
where you dope a small amount of Hooten yum into so-called YAG,
get from aluminum Garnet.
And then you get laser emission around about two microns.
That's two millions of a meter.
And that wavelength is particularly good because it's strongly absorbed by
water, which your flesh contains a lot of water.
So surgeons can cut very precisely with the laser.
And apparently the laser is also so-called self cauterizing so that
when you cut through a blood vessel, it tends to seal the blood vessel off.
So the patient doesn't pull blood,
which is obviously useful.
Holmium uh,
is one of the elements in the periodic table that obeys the auto Hawkins rule.
The auto Harkins rule says that elements with even atomic
numbers are more prevalent than those with odd.
It just so happens that holmium is an element with an odd atomic number.
And therefore it's less prevalent than its neighbors,
which have even numbers in general.
What you would expect is that the heavier,
the element gets the less effect there should be.
But what you see is if you drew a line, it's not a nice smooth line.
It keeps on going up and down, up and down,
even though it was a line overall is decreasing.
And so what this basically shows is that the even numbered atomic nuclei
are on average, more of abundance than their neighbors,
which doesn't sort of make sense at first.
And so you think about how are elements actually formed.
Now you start off with hydrogen in the universe in suns,
that's converted in a helium and it's usually helium nuclei being pushed
together. That help you form heavier and heavier elements.
But once you start with an even numbered nuclei,
then your products are always going to be even so like carbon,
which is six would be three helium nuclei to get a
nitrogen, which is seven.
Then you need to add in a hydrogen from somewhere.
And that seems to be a little bit more difficult to do because most of the
hydrogen had to be used to be turned into helium.
So once you go into a universe with helium,
you're more likely to get even numbered elements. One though,
that is the big outlier is still actually hydrogen.
And of course that's a good job because if it hadn't,
then you wouldn't have water,
which is essential for life and you wouldn't have most of the molecules in the
world, which do tend to be quite hydrogen rich. Yeah. So holmium or base oil,
because if you look at it's near snipers of dispose, yum on erbium,
there's more of them than there is holmium.
So you can see there's a definite dip in between those two,
even numbered elements.
I don't know. I think it's not so much it's forgettable,
but you don't remember it,
which is rather forgettable sorts of means that you think about it and then you
forget about it. I would say you're most people never really think about it.
So.
Say Holman was a little bit pedestrian,
but there's another fact that I've took up about it as well,
which is in nuclear processes. Uh,
you want to be able to control all of those neutrons flying around.
Otherwise things would get out of control. And, uh,
the element that normally gets there,
the limelight where that's concerned is boron.
It's really good at absorbing what a little known factors.
The holmium is actually quite good at absorbing neutrons as well.
So you can kind of use it as a sacrificial element to keep your nuclear
reactions under control.
Well, I suppose one of the things that people have said,
and there's an article in the latest issue of this journal Nate's of
chemistry, and they have an article about
Dave, not tickle about holmium with a,
the catchy title homely holmium in which
the important parts of this article say is that they
think the tone medium is the most underused elements.
Nobody has really found a good use for it. I'm not sure.
I think there may be other elements that would be a strong contender for this
title, but we should let them have their say.
The other thing about holmium,
which I think is important is that it has a pretty prominent
position on this time.
So whoever designed this Thai clearly thought that homeroom was important.
So perhaps they've got a good application.